Silicon Valley as I've told you many
times I think one of the best shows
certainly now but maybe ever I love that
show
well I disagree but yeah okay guys
nominated for the Best Comedy Emmy yeah
eduation you've been to the Emmys before
do you enjoy it do you like it is it a
fun experience for you oh yeah oh yeah
it's fun it's it's a great time it's
fancy it's tart
here's the thing as I was saying you
know for years and years you're just
like a guy you're like a comedian or an
actor or a writer and then you know you
walk down to McDonald's and nobody stops
you like maybe they'll show you on that
UCB show you're funny or whatever and
then you get on the show like Silicon
Valley or something people watch it and
then you'd make that same trip and it
was like everyone was so fake yeah yeah
and then and then what ends up happening
is like if the show's good then you
start going to like these fancy things
like Emmys and after Emmy parties and
pre Emmy parties and it's all fancy and
you wear these little suits these tiny
little suits that barely fit I think
that's your choice and then you know
it's it's like that first episode
actually of the show of Silicon Valley
where everyone's like eating like
deconstructed shrimps and like it's just
a blob of goo and it starts to feel like
The Hunger Games where everyone's got
these crazy hairstyles cuz everyone's
got to be unique and this in this
topsy-turvy world and like you know
someone will be like hi I'm Nathan from
queef magazine can I do a story
wait a minute I was on the cover of that
magazine subscribe to queef magazine
it's incredible the articles the faster
that's high-fashion and like you go to
these parties and like I was at one I
swear there was this fountain and they
had remote control boats in the fountain
and so you could be talking and then
someone be like would you care to race
the boat and like okay and use race or
remote-controlled boat while you're
having a conversation yeah it's very
surreal it feels and also my experience
was there were years and years and years
where nobody gave me anything oh you
didn't have any money and then suddenly
the minute you hit it you go to these
things and they start giving you stuff
yeah and you're like I can pay for it
might now why don't were you giving this
to me ten you're like we want you to
have it and I might put here's a white
tiger you know I would love a white but
how will I care for it you'll find out
the blood of the innocent and and the
the best example of this by the
highlight of something like this is I
was at one of these fancy parties and
very I have to sort of like back it up a
bit so I do this show it's called the
improvised Shakespeare show it's an
improv show and I've been doing it for
years and years and occasionally
occasionally Sir Patrick Stewart will
come in and sit in with us he'll be like
I don't like to do the show
and we're like okay which is great it's
insane so if you ever see the show
there's like a 10% chance that we'll all
come out you'll be like captain lone
jean-luc Picard yeah and you'll see it
he's great he's super funny and I love
him but I was at one of these parties
and it's so crazy there's all these
people you don't know you're eating the
deconstructed shrimp queef magazines
over there and you're like oh there's
training Tatom I can't go I can't be
like I mean can I be a friend you know
yeah and so you stand there and you
don't know anyone you eat those shrimps
you take a photo and you deserve to sit
there and then I swear I mean the lady
we're about to hit we're about to get
out we're like this we feel silly and
then I hear head of the crowd
Thomas oh thank god you're here and I
look over and there's tad you Stuart
like I don't know anyone we're sticking
together tonight
if you would have traveled back in time
to my 15 year old self and said you know
when you're older you're gonna be fat
you're gonna be
jean-luc Picard Captain jean-luc Picard
social life line at a weird Hollywood
event and then I would have kicked both
of humanity No
well don't be approached young man it's
usually to get that's always how that
goes down yeah that was a trying hey
thanks for watching please subscribe to
my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please